[Musique]
je retrouve mes collègues Véronique
prince et Sébastien Bovet bonsoir à vous
deux bonsoir Patrick on va commencer
quand même avec le dernier heure parce
que il avait écrit il y a une dizaine de
jours dans les journaux en français et
en anglais qu'il allait rester monsieur
gentil il entendait les demandes il
avait vu le vote la Chambre des communes
qui lui demandait de quitter
mais il avait dit mon mandat vient du
Premier ministre manifestement Sébastien
la pression était trop forte il a vu que
la joute là faisait en sorte que ça
allait impossible de tenir ça quoi de
façon sereine j'imagine ouais il a été
pris dans cette jeu de partisane mais
faut dire qu'il était lui-même devenu
l'histoire Davy un acteur devient
l'histoire lui-même on oublie la
véritable histoire qui l'ingérence
étrangère donc ça devenait une
distraction et peu importe ce qu'il
disait monsieur Johnson c'est comme si
on n'écoutait plus on retenait
simplement qu'il ne recommandait pas une
une enquête publique pourquoi peut-être
à cause de ces liens proximité mis en
relief par les parties d'opposition avec
Justin Trudeau avec la famille Trudeau
bref à partir du moment où on vous
écoute plus vous devenez plus une
distraction qu'autre chose et vous nous
faites dévier du fond des choses qui est
la gérance étrangères c'était
probablement la seule solution au moment
où Véronique voilà ça arrive et je
posais la question tout à l'heure à
Daniel Ottawa là la question qui va se
poser si on fait quoi maintenant est-ce
que on recommence pour redemande à
quelqu'un est-ce que c'est une bonne
idée de tenir ou pas une enquête
publique où on essaie de poursuivre
c'est pas évident
visiblement ils vont devoir arriver
peut-être avec une liste de noms je l'ai
déjà dit dans un de ces panels ici à
Québec on a développé une formule dans
laquelle à partir d'une courte liste il
y a un vote qui se fait aux deux tiers
des membres de l'Assemblée nationale
donc ce qu'on peut essayer de trouver
une formule ou peut-être qu'on n'aura
pas uneanimité mais au moins l'appui de
d'autres parties là c'est important
l'ingérence chinoise c'est une question
de nationale devrait pas y avoir de
partisanneries là-dessus alors les ouais
c'est difficile mais c'est vrai c'est
vrai en fait c'est un sujet qui est
tellement
mais il y en a eu beaucoup dans ce
dossier là maintenant c'est clair alors
il doit peut-être en arriver à un point
de consensus ou une personne va
peut-être pas faire l'affaire de tous
comme je le disais mais d'au moins une
majorité de députés puis probablement
que le parti juste être retour va devoir
s'entendre avec les autres parties pour
essayer de trouver peut-être des appuis
ailleurs mais si ça avait été ça au
départ si Monsieur Trudeau avait nommé
quelqu'un au-dessus au dessus pardon de
tout soupçon de partisanneries ou de
proximité on l'aurait peut-être pas se
déballeur puis peut-être que le débat
sur l'ingérance étrangère se ferait de
façon non partisane le problème c'est
que les gens autour de Monsieur Trudeau
ont pas vu les dangers que
représentaient des vêtements Stone pour
la crédibilité de son enquête ou de son
travail peut-être qu'un ex juge de la
Cour suprême par exemple aurait pu faire
vaut mieux faire la fête et c'est
dommage parce que ça entache une
carrière irréprochable pour Monsieur
Johnston ce dernier épisode de sa
carrière politique oui moi l'hypothèse
c'est qu'on peut faire aussi pour
discussion c'est que jusqu'à la
prochaine campagne électorale cette
question-là sera fera l'objet d'une
jolie politique et que peut-être
monsieur Trudeau pourrait demander à
l'opposition donnez-moi un nom
entendez-vous comme dit Véronique on
pourrait voter mais je répète ma
question si cette personne XY ou Z
arrive au même conclusion de Johnston
parce qu'il faut quand même revenir au
rapport parfois il dit une enquête
publique ne serait pas utile est-ce que
vous croyez que le blog que les parties
le Parti conservateur MPD va déjà très
bien on vous croit cette fois-ci
s'ils ont au moins participé au
processus de nomination la réaction va
peut-être être moins virulente à ce
moment-là très bien en tout cas une
nouvelle qui tombe aujourd'hui
parce que lui voulait rester mais
manifestement pas pu rester ok fin de
session à Québec Véronique Sébastien
conférence de presse à la queuleuleu de
tous les chefs aujourd'hui on vous a
demandé les meilleurs coups les moins
bons coups pour essayer de
mettre ça dans deux grandes catégories
donc le positif puis le plus négatif je
commence avec vous Véronique les
meilleurs coups de la session selon vous
en a demandé deux chacun là je crois
alors allez-y oui c'est sûr que dans le
contexte actuel c'est difficile de
passer à côté de la gestion de crise du
gouvernement on a vu l'efficacité de
François Legault et son équipe en pleine
pandémie dans le premier confinement
dans les premières semaines là avec son
point de presse quotidien et tout ça
son équipe est lui ont développé une
espèce d'expertise on dirait dans la
communication de crise il est très à
l'aise vous le voyez sur les images sur
le terrain comme ça il va à la rencontre
des gens et l'échange avec eux il amène
avec lui aussi les députés des parties
d'opposition qui dont les compter sont
touchés par ces crises il y en a eu
plusieurs là franchement je me rappelle
pas la dernière fois en excluant la
pandémie je me rappelle pas la dernière
fois où il y a eu autant de tragédie ou
de catastrophes à gérer vous avez eu le
drame à Laval le drame damquouille le
verglas Montréal les inondations à base
Saint-Paul là maintenant les incendies
un petit peu partout au Québec alors je
m'en voudrais de pas souligner
l'humanité dans le fond de gouvernement
puis des autres partout aussi qu'il est
à l'aise donc avec ce genre de gestion
alors le sang Sébastien votre premier
bon coup vous l'ordre que le
gouvernement est en train d'essayer de
mettre dans le dossier de l'immigration
je vais vous résumer ça par une phrase
assez simple on a l'impression que
Christine la nouvelle ministre la
ministre de l'Immigration comprendre le
dossier et qu'elle est en train
d'apporter une approche équilibrée à ce
dossier à la fois avec la commande de
protéger le français et qui vient
probablement du cabinet du Premier
ministre et de répondre aussi aux
besoins économiques du Québec ou du
monde des affaires en augmentant
notamment le seuil d'immigration petit
bémol par contre note de bas de page
peut-être sur les travailleurs temporels
qu'elle ne considère pas dans ses plans
actuellement ça va falloir qu'elle
réponde à des questions là-dessus
pourquoi le gouvernement ne compte pas
ou ne planifie pas les travailleurs
temporaires l'apport des travailleurs
temporaires qui pourtant consomment des
services en santé consomme des services
de garderie et mettent une pression sur
la capacité d'accueil du Québec mais
pour l'instant on a l'impression que ça
va mieux que ça a déjà été au ministère
de l'Immigration c'est comme si vous
êtes on sent qu'elle a fait ses devoirs
et qu'elle a pu influencer l'opinion au
bureau du premier ministre du Premier
ministre et d'autres en disant voici
c'est ce qu'on peut faire qu'on peut pas
faire très bien Véronique autre bon coup
la Commission spéciale sur le hockey
franchement là tous les partis y ont
collaboré puis ça c'était un mandat
d'initiative ça veut dire que
l'initiative venait des députés c'était
pas une commission qui était gérée par
le gouvernement mais c'est un travail
qui était transpartisant si je me
rappelle bien c'est Vincent Marcel de
Québec solidaire qui a dit faudrait
qu'on mette en place la commission pour
pouvoir questionner les acteurs de la
Ligue junior majeur puis après ça une
Rico de Chiconi du parti libérale a dit
ouais mais tant qu'à ça on devrait se
pencher sur le problème des initiations
dans tous les sports là le gouvernement
aussi de son côté qui dit bah on veut
les appliquer les recommandations puis
si ça peut inciter des gens à dénoncer
davantage en fait ça fait en sorte que
les joueurs ne se retrouvent pas tout
seul avec leur recours collectif il y a
des législateurs qui se sont penchés sur
la question qui ont mis la pression sur
les propriétaires des équipes qui ont
mis de la pression sur la Ligue pour
éviter que ça se reproduise c'est sûr
que le rapport qui a été déposé n'a pas
de loi mais je verrai mal les
propriétaires les acteurs importants les
joueurs les coachs etc de cette ligue là
ignorer le rapport puis on va voir
maintenant qu'est-ce que le gouvernement
va faire avec si ça va se transformer
éventuellement législation Sébastien
autre bon coup votre cœur s'ouvre une
autre fois oui je veux vous parler d'une
politicienne dont on entend pas beaucoup
parler qui passe sous le radar et c'est
une bonne nouvelle pour elle c'est
Nathalie Roy la présidente de
l'Assemblée nationale on avait des gros
doutes sur sa nomination au moment où
elle était nommée pourquoi parce que
comme ministre elle était hyper partisan
et on se disait comment va-t-il faire
pour se lever au dessus de la mêlée
comment va-t-il faire aussi pour
appliquer de la discipline à ces députés
élus parfois un peu indiscipliné mais
force est de mettre que depuis qu'il a
pris le poste ça marche elle a eu à
lever la voix quelquefois mais les
députés ont l'air de la respecter il y a
pas de d'indiscipline il y a un peu de
discipline évidemment mais ils sont
rapidement ramenés à l'ordre et il la
respecte des deux côtés de l'allée donc
petit
autocollant dans le cahier de Madame Roy
pour cette session parlementaire mais
c'est noté Véronique
je suis d'accord avec Sébastien je
trouve qu'elle se débrouille vraiment
bien alors que au départ les attentes
n'étaient pas élevées de la part des
Parties d'opposition surtout là on
craignait qu'elle soit trop partisanale
mais c'est pas le cas du tout ok donc ça
fait consensus à notre panel du vendredi
bon les pires coups les pires coups on
s'en doute un peu mais j'ai hâte de vous
entendre Sébastien je commence avec vous
le premier pire coup j'ai commencé par
le salaire des députés non pas peut-être
parce que les salaires les députés ne
méritent pas une augmentation de salaire
moi je pense que il mérite une
augmentation de salaire en fait il y a
beaucoup de gens qui méritent une
augmentation de salaire mais c'est sur
la façon avec laquelle ça a été fait le
fait que les députés décident eux-mêmes
du montant qu'ils vont s'attribuer en
augmentation de salaire mais surtout les
arguments qui ont été utilisés par le
gouvernement pour nous convaincre que
c'était la bonne décision que les pères
et les maires politiciens devaient avoir
les moyens de donner le meilleur à leurs
enfants la meilleure ça a été Éric
Lefebvre le Web du gouvernement qui a
dit
je suis tellement occupé je mérite une
augmentation de salaire je suis
tellement occupé que je suis pas capable
d'aller voir ma mère je l'ai visité
juste une fois l'année dernière vous
voyez donc le type d'arguments utilisés
finalement monsieur Lego voulait faire
plaisir à son cocus après le recul sur
le troisième mien et il a il est allé de
l'avant Véro pas bon coup mauvais coupon
le salaire des députés moi aussi sauf
que je vais y aller sur un angle
différent moi en fait le problème que je
trouve là-dedans c'est le mandat très
restreint qui a été donné au comité
indépendant qui s'est penché là-dessus
qui a fait les recommandations quand
j'ai un mandat très restreint c'est
qu'ils se sont penchés uniquement sur la
question de l'indemnité annuelle alors
qu'il y a quelques années l'ex juge
clair le rôle du B avait fait un travail
encore plus colossal dans son rapport
qui finalement avait été tablette puis
elle disait on ne peut pas s'attaquer
uniquement à l'indemnité annuelle il
faut aussi diminuer le régime de retrait
parce que la cotisation annuelle des
députés c'est 21% du coût total de leur
régime alors que normalement c'est 55
ans elle-même avait qualifié ça de
Ferrari alors peut-être que la pilule
aurait été mieux avalé si les députés
avaient dit regarder on va vraiment
faire le ménage dans notre régime de
retraite mais en contrepartie on va
augmenter notre indemnité annuelle puis
la question des allocations de dépense
aussi un ménage également à faire la
dent mais c'était pas non plus dans le
mandat du Comité on rappelle aux gens
que ça a été voté
et c'est à faire régler 30
000 dollars de plus
autre moins bon coup Sébastien l'abandon
du troisième lien en fait le troisième
lien autoroutier surtout parce que le
gouvernement la CAQ c'était entêté à
vendre ce projet-là au Québec puis en
particulier aux gens de Québec et de la
réussite de Québec sans études sans
vraiment y aller à fond de façon
sérieuse rigoureuse pour dire qu'on en
avait absolument besoin c'est ça le
problème c'est que pendant tant d'années
lac n'a apporté aucune nuance à ce
projet-là puis pratiquement du jour au
lendemain elle a décidé de fermer
l'interrupteur sur le projet ce qui a
choqué et ce qui a fait dire à des gens
que ils se sont sentis trahis parce
qu'il est sur la rive-sud de Québec donc
une décision est difficile à prendre que
certains avaient un peu vu venir à cause
des coûts du projet mais mal défendu ou
mal présenté avec les conséquences qu'on
a connu notamment dans la région de
Québec est-ce que ça demeure la colère
sur la rive-sud de Québec que Sébastien
très vite avant de passer à vous il y a
même un député de la carte qui a dit cet
été je vais faire la tournée du milieu
économiques chez nous peut-être pour
relancer le projet autoroutier ça
voulait ça vous donne une idée que pour
certains c'est pas mort puis il y en a
qui tiennent à ce projet bon Véronique
j'ai pas le choix de parler de troisième
lien aussi parce que c'est
ça a été le dossier
c'est la promesse fort qui a été rompue
alors c'est sûr qu'on a les deux le même
mauvais coup là et ce que je trouve
c'est que non seulement pour la
population ce qui est difficile c'est
que ça alimente le cynisme tellement que
c'était une promesse qui avait été faite
à plusieurs reprises en campagne
électorale ça alimente le préjugé que
les politiciens brisent leur promesse
puis qu'on peut pas se fier à eux etc
puis je pense que ça fait non seulement
mal à l'image de François Legault pochu
dans la région de Québec tu sais mais ça
fait mal dans ces rangs aussi parce que
ses propres députés ont été avisés à la
dernière minute c'est eux qui se sont
retrouvés avec la patate chaude il y a
des gens comme par exemple Luc provençal
dans Bose Nord lui dans son comté il a
21 maires de municipalité alors c'est
lui après ça qui a dû prendre le
téléphone ouais là j'ai une mauvaise
nouvelle à vous annoncer plus c'est lui
qui a probablement dû avaler toutes les
critiques les autres ils étaient pas
contents alors
je crois que ça peut laisser des marques
dans son propre coq
très bien et on reparlera parce que
l'autre session va arriver
cet automne de la réforme en santé et
forme en éducation les Québécois se
regardent ça se disent bon ça chicane un
peu mais veulent des résultats à la
rapidement les deux Sébastien mais dans
la façon de vendre les réformes j'ai
l'impression que le gouvernement est en
train de d'avancer dans la bataille de
l'opinion publique il y a des gens qui
résistent mais on se pose des questions
sur leur résistance en particulier les
syndicats donc une bataille pour
l'opinion publique et le gouvernement
joue quand même assez habilement je
trouve ces cartes dans ces dossiers
Véronique
pour enchaîner sur les réformes moi je
trouve quand même ça demeure un mirage
parce que combien de fois on nous parle
de réformes en santé de réforme en
éducation que cette fois-ci c'est la
bonne que le ça va enfin marcher que les
choses vont rouler que vous allez plus
attendre dans les urgences que votre
professeur va être heureux d'enseigner à
votre enfant ça fait beaucoup de
promesses depuis beaucoup d'années là
les deux réformes ont été déposées mais
comme celle de Christian Duby il y a
tellement d'articles il faut les faut y
aller un à un à l'automne à ce qu'on va
finir par les adopter ces réformes-là et
le voir pour le croire les gens je pense
ont besoin de ça les électeurs
très bien mais merci beaucoup à vous
deux donc les députés qui partent dans
leur circonscription dans leur comté ça
reprend quand c'est 12 septembre pardon
le 12 septembre le 12 septembre quand
même bonne fin de semaine à vous merci
d'avoir été là on se retrouve la semaine
prochaine merci au revoir